and as always we're gonna play the
king's indian which is which is
my main opening and you guys know the
drill by now this is my main opening
and uh i i like to propagate this
to people i'm a big big advocate of the
king's indian
[Music]
now he plays bishop g5 which is a bit of
an odd developing move although it does
make some sense
as we're going to castle and
now okay so he plays something called
the smithslav system named after former
world champion vasily smith's law but he
plays it in a bit of a weird way usually
in this mislove system
the knight gets out to c3 first so
if you guys will remember in the king's
indian black has two main central pawn
breaks
does anybody know what they are how do
you ultimately get control of the center
with your puns there's two ways of doing
it one is more king zindini
and the other is a little bit less kings
indian there's z5 and c5
i got a lot of questions as to like when
you play c5 because usually i give
priority to e5
and this is a great example of when c5
is a better pawn break because
if you guys notice by developing his
bishop he's
weakened the b2 pawn which is now
undefended and
how does the move c5 contribute or how
does the move c5 prepare
a move that would ultimately attack that
b2 pawn what am i
what am i implying here yeah so the move
queen b6 is going to be very nasty
actually
thank you cat rock and mo and that
doesn't mean i'm going to play queen b6
immediately
but just the possibility of this move uh
is is quite unpleasant for him because
the bishop has gone outside of the pawn
chain
so also um i quite like the idea of
going c5 because it keeps the diagonal
open for the bishop so c5 is definitely
a very legitimate idea
whoa alexandra thank you so much
a big honor to be raided by alexander
castiniuk
um welcome everybody we're doing a
little bit of a of an educational stream
right now a bit of a speed run
um i'm not sure if it was a russian
stream or an or an english stream
was it was it a russian stream
or was it an english stream english nice
all right very cool um
so he's gone d5 let's continue the game
now we have to understand
as i always say when a move like this is
played what are the
effects what what effects does this
create what i notice here is that this
opens the
this opens the long diagonal for the
bishop
uh okay so what does that mean how do we
exploit the fact this long diagonal has
been opened
you know is there anything we can do to
to take advantage of the fact that this
diagonal has now been opened and of
course we can we can go 94.
and by the way you guys remember that i
said it's weird that he hasn't developed
his knight that's one of the
the drawbacks of not developing your
knight is that the e4 square has been
made available to our knights
uh to our knight and now we're
threatening to take on v2 we're not
exactly threatening to win the bishop
because the knight defends the bishop
but that's a pretty valuable bishop to
take i mean you don't just want to go
around giving away your bishops like
that
um and so i would definitely take on g5
given the opportunity
so let's see what he does okay bishop h4
what do we do now
and that is a kind of an admission of
defeat
and now our strategy has ultimately
worked
yeah we take on b2 and he's actually
kind of busted here because
as you guys will notice the amazing
thing is he can't even get really a
piece for the rook
and and the most obvious move here is
knight b to d2 which would attempt
at least to link the queen with the rook
but after knight bd2 we wouldn't take
the rook immediately i'll talk about
that if he plays it
so that's why c5 in that position is
okay
so one of the mistakes i often have
talked about on on the stream is
when it's on the concept of automatic
moves we're playing on autopilot
and a lot of people here would
immediately take the walk because you
would celebrate you know i won the rook
but it's very important in these
positions to take a little bit of time
because it
may very well be the case that if you if
you spend a couple of seconds you'll be
able to find a big improvement
over the obvious move and if you notice
what do i always say about the queen the
queen is the worst defender on the board
because the queen is very easy to
dislodge
that is exactly what we can do here we
can knock the queen away from its
protection of the rook
with a very cool move knight c3 and if
you notice the queen has no
square is along the first drink it has
to move away but then we take the rook
our pieces will get a little tangled up
there
um but at the very least will cause him
some more trouble
so he does have a way i believe of
winning
that bishop back but we'll see if he
does that
alex you know as you'll see this is
still a better version for black then
than immediately taking the rook all
right so we take on a1
and maybe any some of you guys can spot
how this bishop can be trapped now the
knight is sort of blocking okay so he
didn't quite see it
which gives us a bit of a respite now
this is still not easy though
on my end because he wants to castle
and once he castles uh that bishop on a1
is going to be under fire so it's
actually very hard
uh to to get both pieces out and you
have to come to terms with that we are
going to
lose one of our minor pieces and this
correct strategy here
is to come to terms with that and if we
do we want to give away
uh first we have to decide do we want to
give away the knight or do we want to
give away the bishop
um and let's make that decision
do you guys think that we should give
away the definitely the knight we want
to keep the king's indian bishop if we
give away the bishop
then our king side is going to be really
weak because remember we've played g6
so uh if we've decided that we want to
give away the knight and we want to keep
the bishop and we have to open the
diagonal for the bishop proactively
and we have two possible ways to do that
we have knight takes a2 and knight takes
d5 you guys know
that if you're already giving up a piece
then you might as well give it up for as
much as you can
but if we compare these pawns would you
rather take this
meaningless pawn on a2 or a central plan
i would rather take a central pawn
on d5 you know taking center pawns in
general is a good idea
so this is a classic desperado sacrifice
now we have to be a little bit careful
the diagonal for the bishop is already
open so we do not we do not
need to move the bishop back yet i would
first play the move d6 because if you
notice he was threatening this nasty
move d6
uh using using the pin so now we're up
in exchange and we're
you know basically completely winning
and uh
again as i always say you should never
forget about developing the rest of your
pieces when you want material do not
rest on your laurels instead
just identify which pieces you haven't
yet developed
so yeah knight a6 here is a very
interesting move heading for b4
um and and that's a very much king's
indian spirit
just not not to block the bishop knight
d7 would also have been possible
the knight can also head to c7 by the
way
then i could also head to c7 by the way
so we have this dual idea knights on the
rim are dim
but this is kind of like frankfurt
airport that's the comparison i make
this is merely a transit point for a
better square on which the knight is
doing something you shouldn't be afraid
of that
if you know where a piece is heading you
shouldn't be too worried or too worked
up about
how it gets there i mean sometimes it
has to step on a couple of bad squares
to get where it wants to go now what do
we do here
what do we do here we need to be very
attentive to what's hanging and
what our opponent has led us yeah
exactly knight takes d5 is right i mean
that's just
another free pawn no reason not to take
it and now we've basically destroyed his
entire center
and uh all the all that remains for us
to have you know
a relatively easy win is to develop this
bishop maybe to f5 maybe to g4 although
that's not urgent
uh we'll also need to take care of that
b7 pawn though if we do that
but um what i want to make clear you
guys is that
on knight d6 we could take with the
queen because the pawn is not the only
piece defending this punch so uh what i
want to make clear is this
balance this dichotomy between on the
one hand you shouldn't get too concerned
about taking pawns
when you're up a lot of material when
you're up in exchange you know or you're
up
uh whatever it may be a piece then you
shouldn't go
out of your way to win more pawns but if
if there is a free pawn that you can
just take that doesn't mean you
shouldn't take it
and i want people to to keep that
balance or to keep that distinction in
mind
um if you if you're up material that
doesn't mean you shouldn't take more
material categorically
but it means that you shouldn't risk or
you shouldn't risk your position to take
let's say another pawn
okay now let's drop the knight back to
b6 so we can kind of hit the bishop
and between f5 and g4 where do you guys
think
we should develop this bishop assuming
that he moves the bishop on c4 yeah
so we should definitely develop it to f5
because then we can we extract the most
let's say the most juice out of this
bishop now this bishop is really a chad
giga chat it's it's pinning the queen
and the rook this is like a horrible
situation for white
because if he moves the rook then the p
then the queen is going to be pinned
and if he moves the queen then the rook
is going to be pinned so it's like a
permanent pin
and how can we exploit this one well we
need to find ways to attack the knight
and a wave presents itself which is of
course d5 and move d5 you guys should
kind of
see it intuitively because that's a way
of attacking the pin piece
and i call this the sort of night knife
and fork right in order to cut a stake
you like you stick the fork and then you
cut with a knife it's the same thing
with the pin
the bishop is like the fork to keep the
knight still and then the pawn is like
the knife that's a bit of a gruesome
analogy but i think it makes some sense
well c4 is a good move by the way as
well c4 is a great move
before d5 because if he takes on c4 then
we can take on c4 and go d5 i'll show
this after the game
um i'll show i'll show this after the
game but c4 is also a nice move
yeah but don't confuse the utensil fork
with
yeah i i assume i i understand that that
could be a bit confusing
all right so let me just write this down
okay so move 18
okay so here's the thing
um c4 is actually a very high level move
here because
if we play d5 if we play d5 that
that does work that does work
but you guys notice that he'll be
pinning that pawn to my queen
so there might be some sort of you know
sudden
idea he might have where he like takes
the pawn with this bishop so ideally
we don't want his bishop involved in
pressuring the d5 pundit so the move c4
comes to mind of course a lot of people
are thinking well what if he just takes
on c4
well then i noticed that the bishop and
the queen will be on the same file
and we have a rook on a8 here that can
exploit that then we'll create another
pin so we'll have two different pins
against two different minor pieces
and we don't even need to calculate in
in the event of that uh it just
you can use your intuition here and i
just find it incredibly hard to believe
that in the event of bishop takes c4
rook c8 he's going to have a way
to escape the pin now we go d5 and this
pawn is quite a bit safer
now that it's no longer pressured by the
bishop i i hope it that makes sense
um maybe i didn't explain that in the
best possible way but you get the point
i think
um okay so cyber is
he's trying to find some sort of way to
save now the only pen that i i have to
be concerned about is this bishop but
um uh you know what i'm thinking of
doing guys and this is a bit of a
radical
question i've been doing this 10 minute
speed run thing
but um i actually can request i can
reset my rating my 10 minute rating and
then do like a proper 10 minute speed
run where i play like non subs or i
could just do another one with five
minute
like honestly i can just do another five
minute speed run
and um i feel like that might not be the
worst idea
but 10 minute might be a better idea in
general because it allows me to explain
my moves in a more let's say
mindful way during the game but we'll
see
so this knight is going to c3 that's the
idea now we can go c3 we can just push
the pawn forward
i'm not commenting on these moves
because the wind is so straightforward
the wind is so straightforward here
correspondence chess beat uh no
okay let's go bishop back to f5 i did
allow him to take on f5 and then take on
d5 but it doesn't matter my pawn on c3
okay
so now um oh now if we take here he
wants to play knight f5
thank you michiko but uh in playing e4
he's exposed well
let me think yeah this is actually i'm
actually going to
there's many ways to win this position
i'm trying to find the cleanest we're
actually going to take on e4
10-minute random opponents might be nice
yeah i actually screwed this up a little
bit but it's it's fine it's still
completely winning
yeah queen b6 was my idea but i made a
small blunder here
doesn't change anything yeah i missed
this move bishop f2 but now we go queen
b2 and it's still completely winning
um it's still completely winning thank
you jackman 1337 for the prime
okay he takes on e7 we go back now we're
attacking his bishop and we want to push
the spawn down to c2
yeah it looks like 10 minutes is winning
i'll ask for my account to be reset
and i'll do the thing i did previously
where i lose a bunch of games
to stabilize my rating
well the reason i'm not doing it to 3
000 is because there's no opponents
there's no five minute opponents
at the level of like 2 500 i'm already
having having a lot of trouble finding
opponents
but i will eventually get back get up to
2500 that's what i promised
i'm i'm close to 2 500 guys but you know
i'm trying to do
what what people are into at the moment
thank you alert thomas gifting to
terrastino matos
okay no problem so now we're going to
deploy the rook and
involve it on d1 and that's going to be
the crusher
okay so let's let's analyze yeah you're
very welcome my pleasure now
this was a king's indian this was a
king's indian
and um the best way to play the system
that you played
is actually to go knight c3 and this
move does a couple of things
as we know it it um i mean that wasn't
that wasn't an internet problem actually
it really never is it was a
problem with my obs my streaming
software freezing
um so first of all this covers the e4
square
um and and that doesn't allow the move
94 which i played later in the game
and the second thing it does is it
blocks the bishop's control of the long
diagonal so in case i play c5 you can
play d5
and of course this knight really can't
move to anywhere meaningful
okay so after knight f3 castles you
still have a chance to go knight c3
um but already in this position this is
your last chance to go knight c3 if you
go knight c3 here
of course i can take the pawn but you
just take back and
uh this is fine for i mean white's
position is completely fine here
um but after d5 knight already the
position is quite nasty so you
absolutely have to develop this knight
in these positions it's very important
it's very very important i'm going to
challenge bortnick on my other account
in case in case he wants to place in
32nd
so what should white do here what is the
priority in these kinds of situations
when you feel like you're in trouble
you have to prioritize i mean you need
to figure out what you need to do first
and the top priority is to defend this
pun
i think you misprioritized here you
wanted to save the bishop i get it but
you can't do everything here
so what would be a good way to save this
pawn
and yes white has to give up this bishop
and yes that is quite nasty but at least
white is
alive here what would be that
that move yeah queen c2 is the best here
take stakes and yes black can play e6
and i can open up the attack on the
knight this is like an amazing benoni
if any of you guys play the benoni
you'll know the structure
black is better here without a doubt but
at least white is not losing material
and you can
complete your development and you can
play so i think that you got a little
bit overwhelmed with the
defensive task and after bishop b2
already now the position is quite bad so
i think that the the last chance you
really had to get a
a reasonable position you can actually
win this bishop straight away
and you can do that by playing knight to
b3 and now the bishop is trapped so what
would black have done here by the logic
that we have applied
and we applied the same logic during the
game what would be black's best way
to gain as much as possible for the
bishop thank you annan log for the prime
it would be knight takes d5 right so
this would give white a choice and it's
not a pleasant choice if c takes d5 then
you can drop the bishop back
and that's a big win for black but if i
were white here i would still
go go ahead and take the bishop and at
least leave black's king slightly weak
at least that would
create some sort of technical
difficulties for black but after knight
before of course the position is still
quite
quite lost uh in any case that's that's
the lay of the land now i take
everything and i get everything here i
save the c5 pawn i get my bishop back
and i'm able to bring it back to a very
nice safe fiance square now knight a6
knight c7
and here i mean maybe e4 to save the
pawn would be slightly more resilient
but
um after this move the game was
essentially over
and um knight b6 bishop f5 this is all
very simple just the last thing to
explain
after c4 if bishop takes c4 uh then rook
ca would have been absolutely crushing
because these two pins from from
different angles
are generally quite quite devastating
and uh
if he goes bishop takes f7 you just take
on f7 your upper rook
and the thing is white's given up upon a
piece for a pawn but now white can't
even save the knight either because the
queen has to move along this diagonal
and uh and after d5 we win we win the
night as well so this is like the worst
of all worlds for white
um and and that that just wins the game
um there's some white of a pretty heavy
lead in development yes he does but
here's the thing leading development is
a is the sort of thing that's often
misunderstood
i would say this um you need to
categorize advantages
as you would do in like real life you
know there's money
uh there's like cash and there's gold
and gold and i i
am completely out of my out of my depth
here but that's the way i say gold is
sort of an intrinsically valuable thing
right
for instance gold is something that we
all agree has this sort of intrinsic
value because it's rare
now and i would compare that to a
material advantage if you're ahead in
material
it's like you have gold now because a
material advantage can
can essentially win you the game because
of its own existence right if you're up
a queen
that itself is going to give you a win
but um
a leading development is like bitcoin or
it's like cash where
you know that itself is not going to
become make you
you know give you anything that doesn't
have an intrinsic value i think
um but you have to trade it in for
something
in order to get intrinsic value so a
development advantage itself is not
going to win you the game you have to
convert that development advantage
into another advantage such as a mating
attack or
a material advantage you have to
transform it and you have to separate
uh those kinds of inherent or intrinsic
advantages from those that are
transformative advantages the ones that
you have to transform into something
and that includes a space advantage
development advantage or even something
like a weakness on your opponent's end
like a weak pun
has to be actually won in order for it
to be meaningful
okay uh so it it the the intrinsic
advantages are very few there's a
material advantage
and let's say a mating attack is also a
an intrinsic advantage because a mating
attack
can literally win you the game uh that's
an advantage which itself
can contribute to victory uh but every
other type of advantage
is is not meaningful if you can't do
anything with it
sorry for the for the long speech here
but the thing is here yes white is a
development advantage
but because i'm ahead of material and i
have such a solid center
there is nothing that white can do to
transform that advantage into anything
meaningful